minecraft takes a stand on nfts discord
and xbox team up and more
minecraft developer mo yang is making it
clear that it will not allow blockchain
technology like nfts to be integrated
within its massively popular game
stating it believes nfts to be quote
inconsistent with the long-term joy and
success of our players nfts or
non-fungible tokens are digital assets
on the blockchain like jpegs of artwork
or even in-game files that one purchase
grant ownership of that particular file
however those files can be and often are
copied or stolen calling into question
exactly how valuable these digital files
truly are as mo yang explains in a new
blog post allowing server owners to
implement nft integration and play to
earn features which could reward players
with nft forms of in-game skins and
items would take the quote focus away
from playing the game and allow for
profiteering the crux of the matter
comes down to the fact that allowing
players to earn nft rewards would create
an ecosystem of haves and have-nots
which goes against minecraft's values of
inclusion and playing together
in other news xbox is finally
introducing built-in discord support
today select xbox insiders will be able
to try out the integration while
everyone else will have to wait for the
support to expand in the coming weeks
this new feature seems to only support
voice chat and not discord's text-based
communication there is also no dedicated
app on xbox yet so make sure you have
your mobile device ready because you'll
need it to transfer audio over to the
console using the new join on xbox
button once you're in a call that's been
transferred over you'll be able to see
who's on the call with you and who's
speaking the same as if you were on
discord on mobile or pc you'll also be
able to adjust sound as well as switch
between discord voice and xbox game chat
last year playstation invested in
discord but it was only a minority
investment the chat service seems to
have no interest in being acquired at
this point in time as a report
circulated last year that microsoft had
considered acquiring discord for around
10 billion dollars though the latter did
not go through with it switching gears
to diablo immortal following a new
update players will be able to convert
their current character into a new class
every 7 days at no cost the swap can be
made at the new shifting flames brazier
in west march and players will have the
option of immediately reverting back to
the character's previous class should
they decide they made a mistake blizzard
states that it will not allow players to
purchase the ability to change classes
more frequently characters that undergo
a class change will have placeholder
gear with an equivalent rank to the gear
equipped by the player prior to the
class change and gear equipped by the
previous version of the character will
be placed in the player's inventory man
i really convinced myself that i was
gonna play diablo immortal a decent
amount when it first released i'm
nowhere close to the controversial end
game let me know if you're still playing
it and what you think of today's nft
minecraft news as well as the discord
xbox news and i'll see you tomorrow